info intox avec Anthony Saint-Léger
bonjour Anthony bonjour Raphaël bonjour
à tous à peine arrivé à la certification
payant des comptes souhaités par elon
musle nouveau directeur général de
Twitter et suspendu effectivement
Twitter blue c'est son nom cette petite
coche bleu un sésame pour beaucoup un
nouveau moyen de rendre les comptes
certifiés de quoi s'agit-il précisément
et bien d'un forfait mensuel pour 7
dollars 99 pourquoi pour garantir
justement l'authenticité des comptes qui
souscrirait la possibilité aussi de
poster des vidéos et des audios beaucoup
plus longs et réduire de moitié les
publicités c'est en tout cas les buts
affichées par Elon Musk dans le but
justement de démocratiser le journalisme
nous dit Elon Musk et aussi de rendre le
pouvoir au peuple exit donc l'idée que
le badge bleu serait uniquement réservé
aux comptes avec de de nombreux abonnés
au compte dit officiel qui aurait validé
leur identité une coche gage
d'authenticité de légitimité aussi
donner à celui qui est prêt à la payer
pour faire de Twitter la source la plus
fiable d'information sur le monde dixit
là encore Elon Musk ironie le réseau
fait depuis quelques jours la une pour
un torrent de des enfants
au faux compte qui se sont faux compte
certifiés bien sûr qui se sont
multipliés effectivement parce qu'il est
encore plus difficile dans ces
conditions de distinguer les vrais des
faux comptes ou des comptes parodiques
comment connaître la différence entre
l'ancienne et la nouvelle certification
suspendue actuellement et bien il
fallait cliquer sur ce badge bleu et là
vous aviez deux messages soit celui-ci
le compte était certifié parce que le
compte était reconnu comme ayant une
certaine notoriété une un caractère
officiel soit le compte était certifié
parce que l'utilisateur avait décidé de
payer les quasiment 8 dollars par mois
résultat on a pu voir des faux comptes
pululés sur les réseaux sociaux comme
par exemple ce faux Georges Bush à qui
il manquait de tuer des Irakiens une
référence assez glauque et glauque
pardon et choquante évidemment à la
guerre en Irak de 2003 mener entre
autres par le président américain de
l'époque un autre président américain
Donald Trump un faux Donald Trump et
évidemment qui vous voyez prend tantôt
la responsabilité pour le l'assaut du
Capitole le 6 janvier reconnaît que
Barack Obama était le meilleur président
de actuel et puis enfin de tous les
temps et reconnaît aussi la victoire de
Joe Biden alors là évidemment les faits
que sont assez flagrants mais parfois
vous allez le voir c'est beaucoup plus
sournois voire vicieux plus subtil en
tout cas regardez ici
ce faux tweet du faux LeBron James le
basketteur américain faux tweet qui
évoque une demande de transfert pourquoi
ces sournois parce que lorsque l'on a
pose ici le vrai compte du basketteur
vous voyez que la photo de profil est
exactement la même vous voyez aussi que
le nom est exactement le même seul
change et bien le l'identifiant que l'on
voit ici en l'occurrence avec des
lettres minuscules pour le vrai des
lettres majuscules pour le faux et une
lettre de différence le Z ici et le S
ici le faux tweet donc de LeBron James
Twitter qui a été aussi l'arroseur
arrosé puisque un faux compte Twitter
pourtant certifié à publier ce faux
tweet qui renvoyait vers un faux lien
d'inscription vers Twitter blue le
fameux service payant donc certains
Twitter rencontrer un succès inespéré
aux conséquences dramatiques
effectivement des conséquences
pernicieuses même pour le laboratoire
pharmaceutique américain Élie Lili un
compte certifié donc par le nouveau
système à publier ce tweet qui annonçait
donc l'insuline qui a actuellement vendu
aux États-Unis serait désormais gratuite
conséquences ce tweet il a été
rapidement relayé rapidement aussi
partager et il a eu des conséquences et
pas des moindres puisque en quelques
heures seulement l'action en Bourse à
chuter 6 % environ et a perdu le groupe
a perdu 16 milliards de dollars ce n'est
pas rien l'entreprise a même dû corriger
le tir et présenter ses excuses pour un
tweet qu'elle n'avait pas écrit et
rappeler les références de son vrai
compte Twitter ça a permis aussi de
relancer le débat sur le coup de
l'insolite ça a provoqué cette fausse
annonce évidemment le désarroi des
patients qui souffrent de diabète
puisqu'il faut le rappeler le coût de
l'insuline c'est environ 1000 dollars
par mois lorsque vous n'avez pas
d'assurance maladie le sénateur
démocrate Bernie Sanders s'est engouffré
dans la brèche et à relancer donc le
débat sur les coûts exorbitants de ce de
cette insuline en dénonçant la cupidité
de l'industrie pharmaceutique pour
tenter d'éteindre l'incendie face à
cette déferlante de faux compte et bien
Elon Musk lui a remis sur pied le badge
officiel le badge gris attribué à
certains comptes une option qui avait
été mise en place la semaine dernière
mais supprimer seul seulement quelques
heures après avoir été déployés mais
qu'on se tiennent prêt Elon Musk a
prévenu la semaine dernière c'est
prochains mois Twitter fera de toute
façon des choses
idiotes ça le mérite d'être clair sera
gardé ce qui aura fonctionné merci
Anthony info intox c'était avec Anthony
Saint-Léger restait avec nous nouveau
journal dans